bring up that article i told you about
this this article
listen to this by the way this is listen
to this
this is the title of the cnn article
depression drove her close to suicide
now olympian raven saunders wants to
quote destigmatize mental health
um and and good for her but
the idea that she was close to suicide
and then she discovered the shot put
is troubling
since returning from the 2016 rio
olympics her mental health had spiraled
sitting at the wheel of her car her mind
was now drawn to a dark place
from which there seemed to be no return
as she circled past a drop-off along the
mississippi highway
the urge to veer off the road towards
the towering trees
below was almost overwhelming this is
nice huh
this will be a nice montage they do
just have her sitting in her car they'll
recreate it they're like
can you take us through the route where
you thought about driving off the
highway
we want to film it we want to have like
a little compilation before you go up
and and lose
it was like no one really understood the
pain and the challenges i was going
through
saunders who placed fifth and the shot
put this is what i mean
if they if if they go and it doesn't
happen
it's curtains
it got worse and worse and worse and
worse till it all boiled over
i remember in the morning just going
through the motions kind of being in a
daze
having things to do but not really
having any motivation
or any care to really get anything done
then hopping in my car and driving and
looking at that spot
a few months before saunders had
considered how the chances of survival
would be slim
if someone was to drive off the edge of
the same drop-off she now circled past
however it was an impromptu text to a
former therapist really a last-ditch
effort
that saved her life she soon received a
response
was it better help providing her with
the re
assurance and courage to go home and get
the help she needed
today she's preparing for the olympic
trials in june
with the prospect of her second olympics
looming
she wants to quote destigmatize mental
health
and help others who like her can get
caught up in cycles
of depression and anxiety so these are
the
types of stories you're going to hear
at the tokyo olympics i mean if you
think i mean there's not going to be any
more
cute like you know
stories where it was like you know this
athlete
you know we always knew they were
special it's gonna be like
i wanted to hang myself
and then i decided that my only hope
was [ __ ] synchronized swimming
i had an eating disorder for many years
where i would vomit up
everything that i ate but then i
realized that that positioned me
perfectly
to be a synchronized swimmer and and i
like it because only my legs
show and the rest of my body's in the
water because i still can't look at
myself
without wanting to purge but i can look
at my feet
and those are the only things that come
out of the water i keep them perfectly
pointed
i mean get ready for the tragedy
like you have never i mean
it's going to be and it used to be like
they were athletes
and it was like you know great athletes
that had like worked their entire lives
at being athletes now it's just going to
be people
who you you're worried about and you
don't think they should
you actually go we don't think you
should go we don't think you should do
this
like after i read that i go i don't know
if you should do this
this might what happens if you lose
again
what happens if she comes in and this
time she comes in seventh
it's back to the car isn't it
that's a problem she's gonna be driving
on that same
[ __ ] stretch of highway
it's gonna be sad and now with kovid
i mean there's going to be like some
memorial in japan
to cove which people are still dying of
covert by the way yeah osaka is getting
yeah they're getting ravaged so what
they're gonna do is like you know like
if they're just gonna like they're just
gonna release like
you know those lanterns into the air and
one represents everybody
who is still in a hospital bed
it's gonna be it's gonna be very strange
olympics
i think we don't need it we can skip it
who believes no one believes that
they're gonna be in the olympics by the
way
like no one gets like very few people
get into the olympics
nobody like my mother was a swim coach
and i think a few of those people got to
the olympic trials it's
very very tough to get into the actual
olympics it doesn't
motivate anybody it might
you know but i just don't think it
it matters anymore it doesn't really
matter anymore and i don't i don't
remember the last time anyone i know
said did you see the olympics i don't
care i don't root for america i don't
care who wins
i don't really care i mean that's the
other thing does anyone give a [ __ ]
if your country beats another country
no one really cares anymore
we've gotten soft here we're probably
gonna lose
and aren't these people all junked up
anyway aren't these a bunch of drug
addicts
i mean they have to they have to test
them like nine times
to make sure they're not like skin
popping
steroids in the locker room right before
they get in the pool
aren't these little junkies anyway i
mean we've just created a race of
junkies to perform these people some of
them have
natural talent but but everybody's
doping that's what the olympics is
it's a bunch of it's it's like a bunch
of lab rats
doping and i don't i don't get inspired
by it is my point i'm uninspired by the
olympics
i don't need it and i don't know why you
need it
but it's it's a it's an antiquated idea
i understand that people think it's
important but it's not
just leave it alone that's my
take on it i don't need to see a bunch
of drug addicts
run around and do hurdles i can skip
that
and i think you should too and i don't
need all the stories
about she was raised by a single mother
in the bayou
you know and now she does
hurdles good
good moving on like i just don't
i don't need that it's going to be
and here's the other thing about
destigmatizing mental health you know
i'm let me say this at the risk of
offending anyone
can we destigmatize people who aren't
mentally ill
because i believe they are getting a lot
of pushback right now
in society the people who are not insane
i feel like are having a much tougher
time of it
mentally ill people
and not real mental illness like my
mother has like schizophrenia
but i mean mentally ill seems to
kind of be a little bit of a benefit in
certain industries
certainly the one i'm in can we perhaps
destigmatize people who
don't want to kill themselves is that
okay
is it okay that someone doesn't want to
kill themself
anymore can we destigmatize
that experience in life people who
don't want to take their car and drive
it off a road
do you think they have anything
interesting to add
everything now is about destigmatizing
mental health which i don't even know
what that means how about
funding it fun give give it funding
and help people that are insane i don't
know what destigmatizing mental health
means
and they're rarely talking about like
schizophrenia or multiple personality
disorder
it's always anxiety and depression it's
never
any of the serious real bipolar
it's always anxiety and depression which
can be real and can be serious
but also there's a lot of people that
are diagnosing themselves off of
instagram
and they really have no idea what they
have uh
they're fetishizing mental illness it's
becoming their identity
and uh they're leaning into it and this
is i am a person that understands this
because i have a mother who's seriously
mentally ill
like real mentally ill like not like she
doesn't have a twitter
they're not doing a profile her and uh
in rolling stone chris cathered
like she's actually mentally ill it's
not like a way to just
put a bunch of young kids in a room and
make money on them
just she's got an actual problem so
that's my concern only my concern is
that
but no it'll be fun get me some uh get
me some
uh inspirational olympic style music
okay
i wanna i wanna read this again with
some inspirational
olympic i just love on youtube tim
dillon discusses birds
oh from that that was a good idea i
don't even remember sex traffickers when
the bird was screaming outside
yes um olympic sport music free no
copyright
there was not a day that went by that
she didn't feel like taking her car
and driving it off the road she imagined
the sweet release of being plunged into
sub-zero freezing water
she had read she would only survive for
60 seconds and that was okay with her
as she could feel the water literally
choking her
her body all of her extremities losing
feeling as she slipped into the darkness
which she called home the final comfort
her final resting place as she thought
about taking that
sweet barrel of a gun and putting it
right in her mouth
blowing her brains out of the back of
her head not one day went by
when she didn't think of lighting her
house on fire and
locking herself in the sweet smell of
her burned flesh
signifying that her earthly race had
been run
but then she discovered
pole vaulting and that changed her life
his mother and father raped him
constantly they would
they would they would sell him to other
pedophiles in the community
when he was a young boy he learned
a deep sense of shame after killing both
of his parents and then being
and then being sentenced to a juvenile
hall for only three years because of the
heinous nature of their crimes against
him he finally started running
ironically something he should have done
years before
he ran and ran he jumped over hurdle
he finally found his sister his
long-lost sister later in life
and she ranked him and that gave him the
strength
to pursue his dreams of running and
jumping over hurdles and now he is here
to compete in the tokyo coveted games
this is a very inspiring story
this young girl for many many years
was a nazi
raised in a small quiet suburban town in
georgia
she discovered the alt-right at a young
age she started live streaming
started asking questions about jewish
people and the shapes of other people's
skulls
for many years she became a [ __ ] poster
she fought against misogyny in the
alt-right online community
for many years establishing herself
as one of the preeminent [ __ ] poster
trolls
in the neo-nazi gaming community
then she left all that behind
to swim at the tokyo games
no longer a nazi though not really
comfortable with
everyone different races we did observe
that she was a little weird
but she's here now leaving all that
behind
to be an olympian what she was destined
to be
we are investigating an incident where
there was a swastika in the pool locker
room we're not accusing her but we're
not
we're not exactly exempting her either
but that's what you're gonna get
at the olympics this year it's just
gonna be a horror
beyond human comprehension and you're
just gonna have to sit there and go
oh good who's competing now it's the
ex-nazi versus the person whose parents
repeatedly raped them
oh tough call
we don't know